direction les outre-mers lettre ouverte
destinée à emmanuel macron signé par 53
personnalité plus d'une centaine
d'associations alerte sur le manque de
moyens
concernant le système de santé en
outre-mer des inquiétudes portant
également sur les répercussions de la
pandémie au niveau économique ou encore
social
annick girardin ministre d outre-mer est
attendue à mayotte pour une visite
officielle de deux jours on en parle
justement avec patrick karam il est
président d'honneur du conseil
représentatif des français d'outre-mer
est à l'initiative de cette lettre
monsieur karam bienvenu merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
dans cette les vous préciser que les
territoires d'outre-mer sont passés tout
près d'une hécatombe qu'est ce que ça
veut dire concrètement ça veut dire que
s'il y avait eu plus de cas ces mêmes
territoires n'aurait pas pu faire face
de lui un très claire de ponte quantifie
covit 19 avait dans une note du 8 avril
prédit le pire ce conseil scientifique
avait annoncé que l'épidémie pourrait
exposé explosé avec trois ou quatre
semaines de décalage par rapport à
l'hexagone mais avait porté plus de
risques des risques qui était lié à la
faiblesse à la vétusté aux carences en
infrastructures de santé et ce conseil
à noter déjà que les risques étaient
aussi une paralysie très rapide du
système de santé de temps que l'épidémie
de dengue sollicitait déjà 17 capacités
sanitaires
pour vous donner un exemple l'île de
mayotte le compte que 300 lits rochette
chu alors qu'il faut en temps normal
neuf cents 300 lits le quart des liens
réanimation n'a pas de respirateur et on
compte seulement une quelques dizaines
de lits en enrayant sur la guadeloupe et
la martinique c'est 50 lits d'hôpitaux
qu'on parle ligne par tranche de dix
mille habitants on voit bien on est très
loin du compte et heureusement
heureusement les prêts ferons
immédiatement réagir premier qu'un
premier cas ce qui a d'ailleurs été
suscitée par des bateaux de croisière de
rosières qui avait accosté des préfets
n'avaient pas réagi
et c'est une partie de ces cas est en
notamment antilles et à la réunion
une partie de ces quais du directement à
ces arrivées de bateaux de croisière
mais très vite très vite les préfets ont
pris la mesure des choses et ont mis en
place un confinement généralisée un
couvre-feu et une 14e préventif c'est à
dire que vous arrivez dans un territoire
d'autres mères est bien vrai ses 14 ans
dans une chambre d'hôtel avec
interdiction absolue de sortir à moins
de sortir une heure par jour c'est à
dire de faire une petite promenade mais
dans un certain périmètre et freins et
bien nous sommes passés très près avec
cheveux de la catastrophe parce que si
l'épidémie s'était développée dans les
outre-mer avec avec toutes ces
problématiques qui sont très
particulières avec aussi des prévalences
qui peuvent être liés aux six enfants
ont du diabète hypertension et d'obésité
la situation était catastrophique alan
était maintenant regarder l'avenir tout
danger n'est pas écarté on voit bien
qu'à mayotte ses deux seuls territoires
d'outre-mer à neutre n'être pas passés
en zone 2 d'état finement tout danger
n'est pas écarté
on a t'elle coca qui se développe
aujourd'hui en guyane il faut être
extrêmement attentif mais si on se
projette on se rend compte que
finalement les retards économique la
pauvreté
les cajas criarde des systèmes de santé
d'éducation et bien font que ces
territoires d'outre-mer serait plus
durement frappée par les airs guère plus
belles et des répercussions de cette
crise sanitaire et c'est clair que ce
choc sera beaucoup plus violent pour les
territoires qui dépendent des échanges
extérieurs et du tourisme et notamment
le tourisme international comme la
polynésie à la polynésie sera en
première ligne
le cheikh arabe oui oui en fait cette
crise est là elle a mis en lumière tous
les problèmes déjà existants dans les
territoires d'outre-mer très clairement
cette crise est le révélateur révélateur
de tout ce qui ne marche pas
la cré est là mais conséquences vont
être absolument catastrophique avec des
entreprises qui vont déposer le vidame
manière massive par exemple la réunion
l'adie qui suit 1800 entrepreneur est
signe que 55 % vont devoir fermer
vous voyez bien que ce qui se profile
c'est une véritable catastrophe
catastrophe dans les autres mers qui
dans les économies ont été à l'arrêt
catastrophe pour les gamins qui ne sont
pas allés à l'école et qu'il avait pas
d'ordinateur et qui n'avaient pas la
possibilité d' ennemi internet chez eux
et donc la possibilité de suivre des
cours à distance
qu'as tu as fait aussi pour le tourisme
aujourd'hui on se prépare à dessein de
mettre un des victimes peut-être à des
émeutes de la faim sur certains
territoires
peut-être également âme à des réseaux
dans d'autres territoires
et aujourd'hui il faut que le président
de la république parce que finalement
c'est le président de la république qui
doit être en première ligne
ces terres qui administre des autres
maires mais le véritable dennis des
outre-mer quand nous sommes en situation
difficile quand de tout explose c'est le
présent la république c'est sa
réputation
c'est sa notoriété cette nuit qu'on va
solliciter pour l'autre mère et il ya un
certain nombre de pistes de travail
nous demandons d'abord que le budget du
ministère de l'outre-mer sont utilisés
aujourd'hui vous avez toute une série de
lignes budgétaires qui ne le sont pas il
faut des lois de finances rectificative
est qu une souplesse pour que ces
budgets son utilité nous demandons aussi
immédiatement un abandon un abandon de
créance de l'état sur un certain nombre
d'entreprises extrêmement fragilisée que
ce soit des créé un site quel ou sociale
nous demandons bien sûr la mise en place
de zones franches globales qui exonère
totalement les cotisations sociales et
fiscales
l'ensemble des activités en grande
distribution assurances post est bon sur
tout le territoire et pour le moyen et
le court terme dans les secteurs
agricole de la pêche de l'industrie du
tourisme de l'hôtellerie de la
restauration du petit commerce de
l'économie sociale et solidaire et des
associations culturelles et sportives
nous demandons effectivement une prise
en charge spécifique de l'état et pour
répondre à cette source
cette problématique immédiate immédiate
dramatique du décrochage social
eh bien ils ont envisagé la création
d'un chèque un chèque tout permettent
d'acquérir des biens essentiels et les
tamis financement de ce chèque peut
venir de la dotation de continuité
territoriale qui ne sera pas où tous
sollicités en 2020 bref il ya un certain
nombre de mesures à mettre en place de
manière urgente des mesures concernent
mais des mesures qu'il va permettre à la
république de se projeter sur un plus
long terme dont celui là est nu le
président de la république est en
première ligne sont les décide
aujourd'hui de changer la donne
traversez la table et de revoir
totalement les relations que la
république doit voir avec les outre-mer
et dans ce cas et met en place des
politiques très volontariste il décide
de faire ce que ses prédécesseurs ont
fait c'est à dire gérer l'immédiateté
si j'avais la crise éviter l'explosion
sociale mais sans prendre de réelles
mesures de l'info qui se prépare à des
lendemains extrêmement difficile
monsieur karam merci pour d'avoir
répondu à toutes nos questions rappelle
que vous êtes président d'honneur du
conseil représentatif des français
d'outre-mer est à l'initiative de cette
lettre adressée donc au président et mme
nelles lapereaux merci d'avoir été en
direct